hello good morning everybody
no wait good afternoon everybody start
that over thanks for coming out to the
last session of the day I hope you're
having a good conference are you oh that
was enthusiastic good
so while ago I did the series of code
reviews won a number of services and
applications that I was helping to build
with a company and was taking some notes
about things that I liked and things
that I didn't like and I came up with a
list of 68 items to review with the team
and I thought well maybe I could make a
conference talk out of this and cut out
some of the smaller issues or company
specific issues and that's what I want
to come to share with you today so
talking about building asp.net core
applications
I assume you already have some
familiarity with asp.net core so I just
have a series of tips that I want to
walk through opinion so I'm not talking
about best practices I'm just talking
about the things that I like to see when
I'm in a project and the tips I have are
broken up into solutions and projects
startup code writing controllers writing
client code writing c-sharp code views
and testing let's talk first about
setting up solutions and projects one of
the interesting things well there's
several interesting things that happen
when Microsoft decided to go open-source
with asp.net core and dotnet core one of
the interesting things is that is that
is not that we could get to the source
code because we could always get to the
source code for stuff in dotnet we could
use some sort of D compiler so what was
really interesting was the ability to go
into a github repository and see first
of all how Microsoft would structure a
solution and how they would structure
their repositories and how they would
lay things out on the filesystem and it
was also interesting to read through the
samples and experiments that they would
check in alongside of the production
code and it's also very interesting to
me to read through their unit tests
particularly if I'm trying to understand
how something works so there is a
consistency in the Microsoft
repositories when you look at them
across all of asp.net core and dotnet
core and how they structure things and I
quite like that consistency and I quite
like the model
that they use so first of all you go to
any Microsoft source code repository and
in the root of the rap pop within the
root of that repository which is not
present on this screen but what you
would see is first of all the solution
files in the top level set anyone who is
using Visual Studio can clone the
repository and I'll be blinking up there
also yes
no still blinking I touched it
alright don't breathe now I'll keep
talking while someone figures something
out just try not to look too hard to the
screen and become nauseous where was I
yeah there's so there's a dot SLN file
in the root of the repository so Visual
Studio developer can just get clone the
repository double click on the solution
file and they can you know start working
with the code but what you also see
inside of every repository is there's
always a source repository folder in the
top level of the repository SRC that'll
contain the production source code
there's a test folder so all the unit
tests are in one place under that folder
typically there's a samples folder so if
the repository is a repository for
anything like a framework that's going
to build a new kit package or something
that provides an API that people are
going to consume then inside of that
samples folder you will quite often find
some very interesting applications of
this particular technology so when I was
trying to figure out how authentic ation
and authorization worked in asp.net core
one of the places that I found most
useful much more so than the
documentation was the samples folder
that's in the asp.net slash security
github repository because that they
would just write some low-level code
demonstrating how a specific feature
would work at a very low level alright
we're gonna try some duct tape
okay so I'll talk about some of the
other photos that you typically find at
the top level one of the things I like
to include is a documentation folder so
there's a picture of a solution that
actually has a folder in it called Docs
and with our team members we can check
in information and documentation that
people might need to run this project or
to understand the architecture to
understand the components now the trick
to this as you probably know the visual
studio solution Explorer window that is
pictured there tells a total lie it does
not give you a faithful representation
of the file system behind this project
so when you try to right-click a
solution and say add a new folder you're
not adding a folder on the file system
you're adding a virtual solution folder
and when you put stuff inside of there
it doesn't exist in that folder on the
file system so the trick is in Visual
Studio 2017 and some people might know
this there's this little icon in the
action bar for solution Explorer the
toggles between the solution view and
the folder view and we switch over into
the folder view you do lose some
capabilities but you also get a faithful
rest faithful representation of the file
system so click on this and now when I'm
trying to make sure that files I place
on the file system are in the correct
place and I right-click and say things
like add folder I know that's actually
gonna happen on the file system what I
lose that upsets some people when you
right click on a folder you don't get
the ability to do things like manage
NuGet packages but to me that's okay
because it's simple to toggle back in
here or just do it through the CS proj
file some of the other things I like to
check in are in addition to samples any
tools that you might use during
development on a frequent basis so
command-line tools and scripts in fact
scripts or something I like to check in
and this is just a picture of the
asp.net security github repository with
their samples folder so if you want to
look at something at a low level like
how cookies work that cookie sample is
great because otherwise you're trying to
figure out things while working through
asp.net identity framework or working
through an OID C piece of middleware and
the services a cookie sample is just
straight-up app doc run middleware that
shows you the two most important lines
of codes work with cookie samples the
first line of code is creating a claims
principle and the second line of code is
calling HTTP context sign and async and
passing that principle in with the
cookie scheme and just running that
sample and seeing quick cookies being
issued is everything you need to know so
hopefully this is making sense I also
like to check in development scripts so
now that dotnet who were has
command-line tools and command-line
utilities that provide a lot of useful
features then the more that developers
can do use command line scripts to
automate tasks in a repeatable manner
the better off we are so I like to check
in scripts that developers will use on
the project on a regular basis so if
you're using entity framework and you
want to add a migration and you want to
make sure it happens in the consistent
manner then maybe add an add migration
script that will do dotnet DF migrations
ad and dotnet DF database update if you
are working in some sort of cloud
environment I'm also a big fan of
checking in either scripts or templates
or some something something that
codifies and automates the provisioning
of resources because ideally what I want
to happen is a new developers on the
team they'll do a clone of the
repository they'll go in and maybe fill
out a few parameters maybe just enter
their developer name and then when a
script and poof something inside of
azure appears there's an app service
there's a key vault there's a sequel
database oh that's just provisioned and
all the correct settings are there to
start working in development and it's
the same scripts that you can param are
sized to set up the QA environment and
the production environment and the load
testing environments everything is
consistent for sorry for
for as your visual studio has the
concept of a resource group project
which is where you can add arm templates
with which are the JSON files that
contain all the properties of a
particular Asha resource they can be a
bit frustrating to work with in my
experience sometimes it's easier to use
the azure CLI and just write imperative
code to say go out and create this app
service and then add these three app
settings sometimes that's a lot easier
when it comes to online builds there's
two build systems that I'm familiar with
one is using app fair and one is using
visual studio team services both of
those systems try to be very helpful by
giving you a UI where you can describe
your build so for example without there
I can log in I can say here's my source
code and I went to run this task in this
task and bsts is the same you
drag-and-drop tasks into a UI
to describe how you want to do a build
the thing that drives me nuts though is
when this builds don't work when you're
trying to troubleshoot something when
there's a NPM install command that's
being executed during the build and it's
happening in the wrong directory it's
really difficult to figure out why that
is fortunately both of those systems
also allow you to get away from the UI
and codify your build so for example
without there if I don't want to use
their UI if I want to have more control
I can just check in and out they yamo
file into the root of the directory and
inside of that app Ferragamo file now I
have all the settings for my build the
top-level settings and now their source
controlled and I can see when someone
changes something and it changes the
behavior of the build or changes the
artifacts that are produced and as part
of that mo file you can tell out there
what build script you want to execute so
perhaps a PowerShell script dotnet
builds are typically pretty easy I mean
there's a lot of ceremony here but
basically you do dotnet restore net
build on that test and dotnet Patt and
there might be some other things you
need to add there with NPM and so forth
but that's that's the essence of it same
thing for visual studio team services
they want to give you a UI where you
drag and drop things but it's the same
steps we just solved on a build on and
test on a publish and then place my
artifacts somewhere I would much rather
go into the task catalog and add
tasks for executing a command line
script or axe executing a shell script
or using something like a cake build or
a piece sake build that I actually check
into source control and then I can run
those builds locally and troubleshoot
them and tweak them as well as run them
in the cloud inside a VST I saw out
there something like that and it just
saves time and and I like having the
configuration for the build in in source
control all right let's talk about
startup code so the interesting thing I
noticed is when asp.net developers came
to asp.net core they were looking for
that place that allows you to write
startup code so in asp.net we had the
global ASAS file we had the application
start event and that was logically the
place to put startup logic that's where
I wanted to put stuff that might have to
prep the file system or migrate my
database or run entity framework
migrations those sorts of things then
when developers came to asp.net core I
think they saw startup Nazi s and I've
just seen some of the most bizarre
things happen inside of startup CS
everything from file system
manipulations and database seeding and
so forth to me startup is really just
these days about two responsibilities
the first responsibility is configure
configure services and the second
responsibility is writing configures and
one is configuring the ioc container or
the service provider and asp.net core
the second one is about configuring the
middleware that you want to use a lot of
people who started with asp.net core in
1.0 are also used to seeing a
constructor for your startup class where
the constructor can have some services
injected and inside of the constructor
you would set up things like
configuration and your logger and so
forth ideally I would like to take that
code out of startup Nazi s put it into
program dot C S which is where the
static main entry point is for asp.net
and set up your configuration sources
and your logging as soon as possible so
even rip that stuff out of startup which
leaves you with just configure services
and configure so I've also been on
projects where you go and to configure
services to try to figure out why the
application
it's behaving a certain way or see what
services are rendered and configure
services can easily grow to a couple
hundred lines of code because once you
start adding the MVC framework and
adding some customizations for it and
you configure your open ID connect
services the authentication services and
add some configuration for everything
just grows and grows and grows what I
like to do is come in to configure
services and just see a flat series of
method calls that are extension methods
that developers have implemented to add
the services and all the customizations
that they need so I can see at a top
level
oh we're using MVC we're using security
we're secure we're using a thing called
mediator I'll talk about later we're
adding some sort of data stores and to
me it's a lot easier than to figure out
where I want to go just by putting the
cursor there and pressing f12 and
digging into one of those things than it
is trying to dig through four or five
sections of blocks of code like this
once you're just trying to configure the
MVC framework same thing goes for the
configure method when you're adding
middleware to the application although I
think to me it's okay to allow configure
to branch so I want to be very I want it
to be very explicit what middleware is
installed during development like
browser link in a way that's there and
what little where is installed during
production the production exception
handler to me that's important to see
the difference between those two
environments and how the application
will behave but in other cases if you're
passing in option objects into these
methods and those option objects are
sort of garbling up the clarity of
configure again I would like to write in
a custom extension method to say use MV
use MVC with custom options that sort of
thing and pack that stuff away somewhere
else
and then one of the beautiful things
about asp.net core is your night you're
not just writing something that is a dll
that has to get hosted somewhere you can
if you think of the application that
you're building as a standalone console
application there's some interesting
things that come out of that I think so
going back to that discussion of where
do we actually put startup code if it's
not inside of startup dot CS well
program dot CS with a
static void main entry point that
ideally is where I would like to see
startup code and there's this really
interesting point in time which is right
about here which is in between the time
when I've created a web host builder and
I've told it what it's going to use and
what the startup class is between that
point in time when I build it and when I
start running and listening for HTTP
messages this is a point in time that's
unique in applications for dotnet
because at this point in time I can do
things and I know my connection strings
I know my configuration sources I know
my logging everything's been set up for
me there's a service provider there's a
container that's ready to fetch services
for me that have been configured for
production so it's at this point in time
where I like to do some of the
interesting things that might have to
happen before the application actually
starts listening for HTTP messages so
for example if someone runs this with
dotnet run and says dotnet run drop DB
exit what the application can do is come
in and get an instance in this case for
this project get an instance of the DB
context that the entity framework will
manage for the database and can drop the
database and then perhaps run D
migrations that are in the project and
perhaps seed the database with some of
the sample data or the the lookup data
that has to be in place for the
application to run and then in fact we
could even stop the application so it
doesn't continue to listen for messages
because that's all we wanted to do we
just wanted to get the environment
configured and make use of this
application as an executable and when
you do this yeah instead of showing this
code I just want to point out that if
you're ever working with the host dot
services and you're pulling a service
out you're trying to use it to resolve a
service particularly if you're outside
of an HTTP transaction you want to make
sure that you go through and I serve a
scope factory scope factory is something
that can create a scope that's
disposable so when you're using the
scope to resolve services like so give
me a service you can make sure that
you're not doing something like
accidentally creating a singleton out of
something that was supposed to be
transient because everything will get
cleaned up properly when that's done
and this is another script that could be
checked into the scripts folder for the
project so a developer can just do a get
pull in the morning then run recreate DB
and this will do a dot run drop the
database migrated seeded stop and
they're ready to start working with any
changes that were checked in the
previous day project structure before I
talk about feature folders how many
people know about feature folders by the
way a few I think let me give you a
scenario so I'm gonna flip over to UM
web applications seven and eight very
popular applications we're gonna go far
so well I'll tell you this web
applications seven was created by saying
file new project
give me an NB C application that uses
asp.net identity to allow users to
register and login to my site and when
you do that with asp.net core 2.0 at
least what Visual Studio what that
template will do is generate the all the
controllers and all the views and all
the models that you need to register
users and to do two-factor
authentication and reset passwords all
of that stuff is here on the file system
I also did web application eight also
with asp.net identity but I did it with
something called razor pages so I just
want to compare these two for a specific
scenario so let's say someone comes to
me and says Scott the user is trying to
reset their password and there's some
sort of bug we don't know what's going
on can you take a look at that feature
right I want to think in terms of
features primarily so I want to think
about a reset password what do I need to
do to work on that I want to get all the
files open so I can look at this I'm
guessing that might be an account
controller the users gonna reset a
password they're doing something with
their account so let's go in here and
start scrolling down looking for reset
well there's log in there's register
we've been through three hundred lines
of code it's not there yet
confirm email forgot password ah reset
password there's the get and there's the
post ok I'm one third of the way there I
found the controller code that I need to
look at now maybe I need to look at the
views let me go into the views folder
I'm assuming this will be an account
there's reset password there open that
file out now I want to find the models
for this particular feature so let me
find your reset view model that the
controller uses and now finally I have
found the three primary pieces of the
three primary abstractions that they
need to look at to work with this
feature so what irritates me about this
today is that the model-view-controller
design pattern is about a separation of
concerns so that the controller only
knows about the HTTP requests or some
external stimulus it builds a model the
bottle model doesn't know about each EDP
it doesn't know about the controller the
controller sends the model over to the
view so there's this nice testable
flexible abstraction but the MVC design
pattern ever said that there had to be a
separation of these abstractions so that
they're in three different directories
all over the place right I have a really
actually difficult time working on MVC
projects these days that use the
conventional controllers are over here
and these are over there set up so
previously before asp.net core 2.0 came
along I was really into feature folders
so the idea of feature folders was
instead of putting controllers and views
and models in separate places you would
instead organize these UI layer
abstractions into folders
that to me the way I like to work with
it these folders kind of represented the
hierarchy of your UI so if you have an
admin menu that someone clicks on and
then they click on a button to manage a
season or manage invoices whatever it is
everything about that particular feature
would be inside of here so there's the
controller manage season controller
there's a couple of years in here that
the controller might render and there's
a couple models that the controller
works with so when someone goes to work
on that feature they have one folder to
go to and everything's there one day I
hope it's possible that I can actually
place my unit tasks inside of that same
folder for the future and actually have
unit tests in the same project as
the production code but you know have
some way to magically remove things or
unlink them if I'm not going to do run
unit tests but then everything's in one
place so for previously before asp.net
course we point out I would use feature
folders and actually built a little
nougat package if you want to if you
wanted to install it all you had to do
is install the package and then say
services not heavy atom you see add
feature folders and now you can start
putting views under the features folders
but then something interesting came
around in asp.net core 2.0 which was
razor pages so the second project web
application eats is built with razor
pages instead of controllers and views
so same scenario me the developer wants
to work on reset password' so let me
come into the pages folder and I'm
guessing again this is under account and
oh there it is reset password that's the
feature I want to look at so let me open
the view there's also the code behind
file which has the model embedded inside
of it but just two clicks and I now have
everything that I need to work on that
feature so with razor pages there's not
this artificial separation of here's the
thing that is sort of like the
controller and here's the view and they
have to live apart they're right there
together which is kind of nice and just
to give you a few words about razor
pages in case you haven't looked at them
yet
I do enjoy them they are the real deal
you're still writing razor so the razor
views aren't all that interesting
they're you know the same as any razor
view really that you would render from a
controller for the most part except it
has an app page directive but then a lot
of people think of this as the this code
behind file and say oh Lord is there
view state two and the answer is no
there's no view state there's no
artificial synthetic click events
nothing like that if I open up the page
model for that particular view this is
very much like a controller so you have
dependency injection so you can see
there's a constructor where we're asking
for a service to manage users yes they
define some of their models as nested
classes inside of the page model which
I'm not a big fan of but that's okay I
mean personally if it was up to me I
would probably put that in a separate
file and I would actually create a
folder called register
or a reset password' and tuck the reset
stuff into there so it's even a little
more granular than just dumping
everything into this one folder but this
is how I'm going to bind things when the
user post a form back is going to bind
to this input model I can also use that
input model when I'm a binding stuff in
the UI to display or binding inputs and
it responds to an HTTP GET request and
it responds to an HTTP POST request so
really it's not that much different than
a controller and in fact in some ways
it's a little bit better this post
request you'll notice there's no toke
there's no attribute here to validate
the anti forgery token that's because
razor pages just assume you're going to
be working with HTML forms and every
post operation should validate in anti
forgery token so it just is taken care
of for you you don't have to worry about
developers accidentally missing that so
if you haven't looked at razor pages
give them a try
I think they're awesome to work with if
you're building HTML applications but to
me if you're building API so you use
controllers but if you're building an
application that primarily does
server-side HTML rendering I don't want
to use controllers for that I want to
use razor pages razor pages for HTML and
then when it comes to controllers please
don't allow developers to use temp app
dot use MVC middleware with a route
builder to define templated routes some
of the worst api designs have i've seen
have happened when developers use the
route builder to define template to
route so I've seen api's where there's a
method that takes an ID parameter and
you actually look and that ID parameter
is something like an invoice date and
you ask the developer why are you
passing invoice date is ID well that's
what the template said it said
controller action ID the third thing
always has to be named ID no but so the
solution to that is not to use any don't
use the route builder at all just use
routing attributes because now URLs are
looking developers in the face so they
have to think about the URLs that
they're actually putting together when
they're writing controllers so if this
controller should be part of
a collection of controllers that manage
admin type resources than is really easy
to say yeah let's tuck this in to admin
and to do that I don't have to go into
some nest and some ugly route builder
code and fight with other people that
are adding adding templates at routes
there so the other thing I can do is
it's really easy to change my parameter
name so I don't have to not everything
has to be ID anymore so this one there's
a season ID this one there's a match set
ID so it's I think the route attributes
are the best way to go because they
again forced developers to think about
the URL so the clients are going to use
to consume the API which is good and you
can actually start thinking about
resources and especially you can think
about the relationship between resources
you know how are they nested should
something be underneath of something
else
oh this was yeah I wanted to change that
actually I forgot anyone used mediator
no no but it is a few people
I'll just say think about mediator
because it's not something everyone
should use it's really useful in some
cases and but let me explain what it is
it's basically an in-memory service boss
Jimmy Bogaerts the author of the
mediator library
it's an in-memory service boss so what
you can do is when a controller receives
some input from the user or some
requests it can translate that request
into a message that is put into mediator
and set off over the service boss to
find something that will process that
query or process that command to produce
a result so what it adds like any
messaging system it Ladd's a layer of
indirection between your controller and
the the the code the business code the
logic that's actually going to satisfy
that request for the user so all the
queries and algorithms whatever has to
happen so the good news is it adds a
layer of indirection the bad news is it
adds a layer of indirection so some
projects
you don't need an additional layer of
indirection and in fact it's really
quite annoying to go into an MVC action
and see Oh mediator about send async now
I have to go find where that happens but
if you're in an application
where you need this decoupling perhaps
you're inducing logic that might not be
in the same project or you have to reuse
some of the logic between the
controllers mediator can be a great way
to make your controllers very skinny so
they're not going to be initiating any
database queries or they're not going to
be doing any web service calls all of
that is going to be in code that has
eventually reached when you send a
request to mediator and if you're
building an API a lot of people still
build API controllers inside of projects
that use cookie authentication so just
remember if you have cookies to
authenticate users you have to have to
have to check for and validate anti for
tree tokens and that goes for API
controllers also so then the question
becomes when I'm doing a post to my API
is from JavaScript how do I get an anti
forgery token that JavaScript can use
when it sends something to my API so we
can validate everything and this is just
an example of a cross-site request
forgery token controller
that someone can just do a get request
to slash API slash C surf token and this
will use the high answer i anteye for
jury service in asp.net core to get and
store tokens so there's two operations
happening the one is very obvious the
one operation that's happening is
getting store tokens will return a data
structure that we can serialize down to
JavaScript to say here's the token that
you have to place into every request or
at least every post and post and put in
delete requests when we need to validate
a token that's the token value and this
is the name of the header that you
should place it into because asp.net cor
if you put validate anti for three token
and put that attribute on an API
controller that receives a request
that'll look in the header also as well
as for a hidden form input but if you're
doing from body it'll look in a header
and the other thing it does it's not
quite as obvious is the store bit which
is if the C serve token cookie hasn't
been issued as yet that will that will
initiate a set cookie to send the cookie
down to the browser that is compare
to the token to make sure we don't have
a cross-site request forgery so it
allows JavaScript to work with that
something else in asp.net course to
embrace security policies it was really
difficult for me to understand what was
happening in asp.net core security until
I went into that security repo and
started working with some of the samples
in there we could do a whole session on
asp.net core security but it basically
revolves around very simple things
there's claims a collection of claims
represents a user so the claims you
probably know like key value pairs it
could be first name as Scott is admin
equals true last name is Allan that
would be the claims that are issued by
some identity provider and then when I
went to and permissions could be claims
too so I could have something like can
edit invoice true that could be a claim
then I have policies policies one of the
things you can do is have requirements
that check those claims so what I like
to do inside of applications is when you
we still use the authorized attribute in
asp.net core but when you're trying to
work in an application that has
fine-grained permissions I like to build
policies which are very simple so this
is going to create a policy named is
admin and the policy will require a
claim for a user that is admin equals
true so I now have a policy that I could
apply using the either using the
authorized attribute and specifying
policy equals is admin or building my
own custom attribute user is admin which
derives from authorized and specifies
the policy name so now developer just
has to swap user is admin on a
controller when only administrators are
supposed to be able to get into that
controller talk about views if you're
coming to asp.net corne you're still you
to seeing HTML helpers try to wean
yourself off of them they're actually
the worst feature of asp.net MVC I
always thought and there's still some
that you have to use but for the most
part anyplace where you're using things
like HTML DUP again for more HTML text
box or HTML that input
get rid of that stuff because they're
really ugly they don't blend it into the
HTML so use tag helpers wherever you can
so ASP - 4 that's a tag helper that's
useful in a variety of scenarios you can
use it for labels so it'll pull out the
display name for a particular model
property like name you can use it for
input so it works the same as an HTML
helper it just blends into the HTML
better but it uses the metadata provider
to go out and find information about
this property it knows its type it knows
its name can set the type of the input
it can add the validation attributes
there for client-side validation so HTML
helpers are good you can write your own
HTML helpers it's not too difficult how
difficult could it be you just derive
from a base class called tag helper and
there's a process method that you
override so you can build your own tag
helpers that are processed server-side
to do interesting things custom things
for your application which is also the
case for view components I like view
components very much particularly in
those applications where you might be
rendering a server-side HTML and you
might be building a page that is
composed of pieces from different
microservices so you might have one of
those pages where there's four things on
the screen and they all come from
completely different units of the
business and inside of your application
kind of like the some of the Amazon
screens where they're pulling stuff for
today's deals and the things that you
like and things that are in your
shopping cart but if you haven't looked
a few components any asp.net core
they're very simple they they are very
much like controllers in the sense that
you have this is called a main menu view
component so the name of the component I
would think of it as main menu just like
a the home controller is the home
controller it derives from a base view
component the difference between view
components and controllers is that
controller view components never get
invoked via a URL so they are only
rendered when someone else tells them to
render as part of a view so they have
one method invoke and then it can be
invoked async also and return a task
dependency injection work so there could
be a constructor here asking for
services data access services other API
services building
we're turning of you and you can render
them not with that syntax that's ugly
you can render something like that with
this tag helper syntax actually if you
component : main - menu so it could it
gets kebab cased where capital letters
they all become lower case and there's
dashes between the capital letters but
if you components our nice way to build
the compartmentalised UI so you can have
for independent of view components on
that page that renders four different
things and none of them know about each
other they all do their own thing and
they can't even do their own thing in
parallel which is kind of nice
let's talk about client code when I say
use webpack I think what I'm really
saying is if you haven't jumped on to my
script 2015 and above or typescript it's
really time to do that unless you're not
writing on unless you're writing a
trivial amount of JavaScript but to me
webpack and equi script 2015 features
when they came along the ability to
write modular JavaScript and be able to
say things like import foo from bar was
wonderful
web pack does have a little bit of a
learning curve I think it's gotten
better and the documentation certainly
has gotten better over the years
this is example this is an example of a
web pack configuration file or I'm
basically saying I went to build an
entry so I went to the or I went to
build a file called vendor that consists
of all the modules for third-party code
that I use react and react Dom and react
bootstrap and Axios and exs yeah es6
promise and what web pack will do is go
into the top level of each of these and
study the import statements and keep
gobbling up modules and producing a
single output j/s file because it's also
run all the stuff through our trains
power if need be and then there's
plugins to do things like minification
and these days you can even strip out
dead code and so forth one of the other
things to keep in mind if you write web
pack configuration files is you're not
writing a configuration file in the
sense that it's just static data it's
not a JSON file when you write a web
pack configuration file it has a dot JSX
tension because it's actually code
that's going to execute inside of nodejs
so
if you have complicated things going on
in your build process that webpack needs
to handle you can write code to do
things like let's go out and blob up all
the files that have the extension dot
specs TS and put that into a collection
and then concatenate all the specs from
a different folder and then run some
really ugly regular expression which I
can't even remember what that does
anymore but I'm sure it's significant
I'm gonna skip this slide for right now
but well now let's talk about it so
Steve Sanderson one of the things he did
before he started working on blazer was
implement this project called JavaScript
services one of so if you're using
webpack and typescript and you're doing
all these things you typically have a
lot of command prompts open to do your
transpiling and run your unit tests so
javascript sanderson's project
javascript services if you take a look
at that github repo has some interesting
little where that you can add into your
pipeline when you're inside of
development to sort of hide webpack
behind the scenes and what this allows
you to do is instead of opening up
command prompts and telling web pack to
run and getting all this stuff set up
you just have your configuration files
out there you put this middleware in
there and one the first request to the
website this piece of middleware will
communicate with web pack and start web
pack up to start watching your files and
transpiling your files and when I go
into a file and save it web pack will
transpile it and load it right into the
browser for me so it's just a nice way
to work with JavaScript these days when
you need module bundling from web pack
because it hides a lot of ugliness that
goes on behind the scenes requires less
setup I'm a big fan of con emu or
commander anyone else use those no good
a fair number so once you start doing a
lot of things from the command line
you'll discover that the built-in
Windows command line isn't really that
great so this is Connie me you can do a
Google search for that or sorry this is
commander which one do I have installed
I always get them confused commander you
can do a search for it
and find it download one of the things I
can do that's quite useful for me is I
often have multiple contexts that I'm
working in so I kind of open up multiple
tabs in this window and do different
operations from different areas so
that's happening over here and on this
tab something else is happening over
here so maybe an example would be like
this where in one pane I'm running
webpack to transpile my files and watch
as things change up here I'm running a
tool to run JavaScript unit tests and
down here or integration tests that are
running so they're all on three panes
and one screen and I'll just point out
that these tools are awesome because
watch this you can right-click this you
know this is a developer that wrote this
for developers right if you go into the
settings dialog there's just hundreds
and hundreds of settings I only know
what about six of them do but there's a
lot of power there if you take advantage
of that this screen by the way is set up
using this command so this is a way of
saying yeah Conny news let's start
Connie new and do an NPM run run watch
in this new instance but then I want to
open up something else with NPM run my
test watcher but put that in a new
console that split horizontally and then
run my karma integration test and
another console that is split vertically
and that's how we end up with those
whoops three screens that you saw on the
previous slide that way I also like when
I when it comes to things like feature
folders I also be able I also like if
I'm working with something like angular
which I haven't actually in a while or
react which is what I've been using
lately but not much let other people
worry about it I like to put components
that are associated with a specific
feature in the future folder so what we
might be looking at here yeah what we're
looking at here is a client folder where
common stuff goes so common models
common services common components that
use throughout the application like a
toggle button
but over here inside of a feature folder
there's a controller there's a view that
renders some HTML and there's a
component that is specific to that
particular feature so it's this isn't a
spa it's one of those applications where
you enhance certain pages by adding
react components or what have you
and like I say if I could put the unit
test in here also I would love to do
that
my c-sharp unit tests just have
everything together if you're still
using Bower or some of these other
things this slide is really it took me a
while to convince people look use just
nougat for dotnet code that part was
easy but what I mean by that is don't
use nougat to install jQuery or things
like that anymore and then just use NPM
or perhaps yarn because that's that's
the newest thing to manage all of your
JavaScript and typescript packages so
years ago there was NPM for nodejs stuff
and then there was other package
managers like Bower for the front end
stuff these days all the front-end
libraries like bootstrap and jQuery and
angular and react they have everything
inside of NPM so that's the only package
manager that I need to install anything
that I need javascript DS so I can use
that to install the typescript compiler
and I can also use it to install
bootstrap and jQuery and typescript for
years I avoided typescript because it
just didn't feel right it felt like the
Microsoft way of working with JavaScript
but when they started working with the
angular team there was a number of
wonderful things that came out of that
and today I try to encourage people to
start using typescript because it
actually plays well in the environment a
couple examples would be things like
this module resolution two years ago
with typescript it was very difficult to
encourage or convince typescript to work
the way you wanted so you could place
the files your files where you wanted to
place your files you had to have them in
a specific locations when they
introduced module resolution that you
could set it to node all of a sudden
that would allow you to do things like
NPM install something and then inside of
types inside of a type scripts file say
import foo from bar and typescript would
actually use the node module resolution
strategy to
look for bar and find that module and it
would look inside of new modules which
was great so it's all of a sudden
typescript became a lot easier to use
and then there's this path setting so
this is a TS config file in case you
didn't know that controls the typescript
compiler this is what a place where I
can say when someone says import food
from bar yeah you can look in node
modules but I also want you to look over
here client script look for that bar
module inside of there too so now I can
completely control my environment and I
can layout files the way I went to
layout files and it's much easier to use
now unless you're using Visual Studio so
when I work on a project that has a lot
of JavaScript I have the project open in
two editors Visual Studio code
definitely for the JavaScript and then
Visual Studio code is also a great
editor for c-sharp but if there's things
that you like in Visual Studio you can
have the project open both editors but I
definitely do all my JavaScript inside
of Visual Studio code and typescript
also there's not as many false positives
for one and then I consider www is the
bin folder
so when web pack does its module
bundling and minification and it spits
out a build or spits out my JavaScript
that's going to go somewhere inside of
dub-dub-dub root testing so let me tell
you a little story
about four years ago I was working on an
angularjs project so this is angularjs
1.0 and I had come from a background
where I started trying to do test-driven
development in 2004 that's when I
started and you know from 2004 to 2014 I
kept trying to do TDD and unit testing
and learning I'm learning things all the
time and I have to say I think TDD is a
great way to learn unit testing and TDD
is a great way it's a great way to
design things so if I'm entering into a
domain that I don't understand what the
solution is going to be I still UI love
to using TDD to figure out a solution to
a problem and what I mean by that is if
I'm writing an asp.net
core controller I'm not going to TDD the
design of the controller
just not much benefit to that but I
might unit test the controller so up
until to 2014
I would sell a unit test the controller
so coming into this angular project I
approach it like any large asp.net
project I had done this is the largest
angular project I'd ever worked on I
went it to unit test every controller
and when I unit tested an angular
controller
I wanted to isolate it because that was
one of the principles that I always
followed we isolate things that way you
know someone checks in some bad code to
a little oval component it doesn't break
all the tests it should only break the
tests related to that component
everything is kind of isolated so unit
testing these angular controllers
involved let's skip that writing a lot
of let me skip that mocks and fakes and
stalls so every service that is passed
into that angular controller I would
fake something up in a unit test and I
would test just just trying to isolate
the controller me and three other people
and what we discovered after a few
months of this is that we were still
getting a lot of bugs in production
because things were breaking these unit
tests we were writing piles of code and
they were just not being as effective as
we wanted them to be so I decided to try
something different I said let's not
fake or stub anything let's write test
code and there was a big debate about
this is a unit test or an integration
test I don't care it's just test code
and not fake anything in angularjs there
was this interesting ability to cut
things off at the HTTP layer so you
could you could write a unit you could
write a test that an instantiated a
controller invoked a method it would use
all the little services so the
controller would call service a service
a would call service B service B would
call service C and then service C uses
the HTTP service to try to call an API
well there was a fake HTTP back-end that
you could use an angular to say okay if
someone makes a request to slash API
slash invoices or turn this Jason so we
started testing all the controllers that
way and what I discovered
we were writing probably 10% of the test
code that we were writing before and all
of a sudden the test code became very
effective like we were actually finding
problems when someone changed the
behavior of a service and there was a
complete revelation to me it's like oh
all of a sudden I'm writing a lot less
test code and I feel like I'm getting a
more bang for the buck and yes there's
the situations where someone checks
something in that is just so wrong or
you know I do something when I'm
developing that it's just so wrong and
breaks every test but that's okay I'll
figure out what the problem is I don't
need tests to tell me how to debug
something so fast forward you know I
come off that project and I'm starting
to look at asp.net core and work with
asp.net core and I'm starting to think
about hmm these controllers do I really
want to isolate them when I test them
it's always such a pain well there's two
things in asp.net core that I found
interesting one is the asp.net core test
host so if you go into the Microsoft
github repositories when Microsoft wants
to test their middleware or juice on
what's called an integration level type
testing they have a new get package that
they install into the unit testing
project called Microsoft by asp net
court éstos and it basically allows you
to spin up your application and run it
in memory and fire off requests at your
application without anything ever
actually going over a network socket so
this little bit of code is just a way
well there's some encapsulation here
like it's not just as easy as saying
create server but create server
behind-the-scenes uses some abstractions
from test toast just a few lines of code
to create a server that will have an
application inside of it and now I can
start sending off requests and I can
write a search based on the HTTP message
that comes back from that request here's
another example create a server send off
a request to slash normal I want to get
a 200 status code back to me that was
very interesting particularly combined
with the fact that in with HTTP clients
it's relatively easy to use delegating
handlers or message handlers or
basically to have an in-memory HTTP
client and if you're using entity
framework entity framework core has an
in-memory
in other words just like I did with
angular there's ways an asp.net core to
sort of cut things off right at the data
layer and really focus on state based
testing writing unit tests that are more
of integration tests that sort of flow
through the whole application and just
reach in this case perhaps a fake
database that's in memory so the test
executes really fast so the EF core we
could debate whether it's still a great
technology or not but the in memory of a
provider for the applications that I've
worked on they use it that UCF core has
been very beneficial it's very easy to
set up the entity framework and
basically tell it using a memory
database so is it like sequel server no
because I can't remember specifically if
it if for enforces things like non null
primary Keys I mean you can do things
with the in-memory provider that you
cannot do with a real sequel server so
it doesn't catch everything like foreign
key violations but it's close enough and
allows me to do state-based testing and
I can write tests like this so this is a
test it's just going to instantiate a
controller pass in some input that the
user probably filled out in a form and
we're just going to run through the
whole thing
all the regular services it uses and
just make sure it produces the right
result and to me that's a beautiful test
because there's not a lot of code there
it's easy to read and even better I can
go into the system and refactor things
all I want change services around and
move things all over the place and the
chances are I won't break that test and
I won't have to change or I won't have
to change this code right I won't have
to go in and change a bunch of mocks and
fakes and subs that I've implemented so
for me these days I'm more big on
integration tasks not at the UI layer
but things that test multiple components
at once and get the most bang for my
buck for the for my testing code let's
talk about c-sharp code a lot of people
are getting into dotnet core because
they want to be able to write web
applications in their favorite editor
and favorite operating system but then
host it in the cheapest possible
operating system so quite often those
two things are different as you're
writing on Windows and pulling into
Linux so these are just a couple things
that we ran into so I do want to also
say that if you're in that scenario
you should strongly consider docker
because then you can be working in your
Windows environment but actually working
in an application that's running on a
Linux docker container on your machine
you can catch code you can catch
problems early in but you want to make
sure when you're writing c-sharp code
that you're not making assumptions about
the operating system so we had people
getting caught with some hard coding
slash R's and slash are slash ends
inside of source code you want to use
environment new line because that will
return the properly line character for
the operating system that you're on
another big one was developers doing
some directory plus slash tech file dot
txt and combining strings together
themselves to build a path where there's
instead you should use path combine to
make sure you get the the correct folder
separator directory character in fact
the directory class and dotnet has a
separator char property that you can use
that will return the proper separator
for the operating system that you're on
and just also if you're using
environment variables to discover things
about the operating system like the the
home home folder for the profile or the
service identity that you're running
under those can be different too so
sometimes you have to use expressions
like this to make sure you get both
Windows and Linux and then something
else I've been railing against that
against another opinion about writing
c-sharp I don't like the async suffix
anymore so when I write code that is
going when I write an async method I
will call it sign out tenant user and of
course when I invoke the api's that
Microsoft provides I still have to have
that async keyword there but to me it's
enough to have the async keyword here
there's already a sink and a weight and
there's a sink and when you have async
code bases as you probably know just
there's a sink just ripples up and down
the place it's all over the place
and I felt bad about this for a while
because it made people irritable that I
was going against the coding conventions
that everyone else is using but then I
read this interesting interview or with
the orange juice trope who said
basically whenever there's a new feature
added to a language programming language
people want loud explicit syntax and I
think that's what happened with async
when Microsoft introduced a single
weight it's it's dangerous is that
creating a thread I don't know but it
could cause problem so let's make it
loud and make it put it in people's
faces that this is a sink but now we're
kind of used to it and we want to turn
or at least I want a terse notation so
you know if C sharp version nine just
assume if there was some flag on the
compiler where you could say look just
assume everything is async and they can
get rid of all these keywords and that
would be great for me anyways that's my
email address if you have questions or
you want access to the slides or things
like that and have a good evening
[Applause]